[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen allen die sie vermutlich
eher keine super eingefleischten
Fußballfans sind ob es mit der deutschen
Mannschaft bei dieser WM weitergeht
erfahren Sie live am Ende der Sendung
wir beginnen mit einer Sensation und mit
Poesie
lösch mir die Augen aus ich kann dich
sehen wirf mir die Ohren zu ich kann
dich hören und ohne Füße kann ich zu Dir
gehen und ohne Mund noch kann ich dich
beschwören
Rainer Maria Rilke einer der
bedeutendsten Dichter des 20
Jahrhunderts einer der von Marilyn
Monroe gelesen wurde und von Oliver Kahn
interpretiert wir alle werden jetzt
Neues über ihn erfahren und von ihm
23.000 Seiten aus Rilkes Nachlass gehen
nach fast 100 Jahren in Privatbesitz an
das Deutsche Literaturarchiv Marbach und
damit an die Öffentlichkeit uns alle der
spektakulärste Deal in der Geschichte
des Archivs ein jahrhundertkauf Eva
Schiller
dieser Gang führt zum bislang
schlummernden literaturschatz der jetzt
lagert in Marbach im atomsicheren
Archivraum hier entblättern Sie Rainer
Maria Rilke man steht vor dem Material
und weiß da ist ein Autor den kennen wir
aber nur teilweise sein Charakter ist
eine große Frage der Geschichte
verpackt den Schuhkartons verkaufen
Rilkes urenkelinnen seine Nachlass eine
Sensation jahrzehntelang verschlossen
entpuppen sich jetzt wertvolle Details
Rilkes vor über 100 Jahren eng
beschriebene Notizbücher seine Aufregung
als er die Welt berühmte gedichtreihe
fertig stellt und frohlockt
hat sich nun unerwartet und herrlich
erfüllt die Energien sind da
das geschrieben hat der Dichter probt
jede seiner Zeilen bevor er sie in
Reinschrift überträgt
Rilke hat sich oft beschrieben als einen
Dichter der aus Eingebung schreibt
schauen wir ins Material sehen wir
unendliche Texte an denen er gearbeitet
hat die er korrigiert hat ein
Perfektionist kann man sagen der erst
die Texte dann nach außen gegeben hat
wenn er das Gefühl hatte jetzt sind sie
fertig
Rainer Maria Rilke von seiner Mutter
René genannt weil sie die tote Schwester
betrauert ihn in Mädchenkleider steckt
da sind Familienfotos Rilke Zeichnungen
und Skizzen seine Bücher bei Max und
Moritz ein erstes Autogramm
Briefwechsel wie der mit dem
französischen Bildhauer oder ein
väterlicher Freund Rilke liebt Paris und
oder doch rastlos von Stadt zu Stadt
hadert gefangen in Gedanken
ist als ob es tausend Stäbe gäbe
in der tausend Stäben keine Welt
im Rilke-Projekt vertonen Schauspieler
und Musiker seit 20 Jahren die Werke
eines der größten deutschsprachigen
lyrikas seine Gedichte sind teilweise
wie Songtexte
und das ist das ist für uns auch das
inspirierende ist es möglich dass man
trotz Erfindungen und Fortschritten an
der Oberfläche des Lebens geblieben ist
Texte für alle aufbereiten das Ziel der
Produzenten dass sein Nachlass jetzt für
alle zugänglich wird ist für sie ein
großes Geschenk weil er spricht da genau
das an was wir alle fühlen also er macht
praktisch so ja man kann sagen schon
fast seelenfenster auf und da finden wir
uns letztendlich alle wieder also das
wird sicherlich sehr spannend sein in
den neuen Archiv zu stöbern und das wird
eine große Inspirationsquelle werden für
sie für Rilke Forscher weltweit eröffnen
sich im Marbacher Literaturarchiv jetzt
neue Stoffe auf
23.000 handschriftlichen Seiten wenn der
Nachlass aufgearbeitet ist wird das die
Literatur verändern entstehen wird ein
genaueres Bild von Rainer Maria Rilke
ja und dieses neue Bild wollen wir uns
jetzt mal ein bisschen anschauen mit
Thea Dorn sie ist Schriftstellerin
Literaturkritikerin und Moderatorin des
literarischen Quartetts morgen wieder im
ZDF vor down guten Abend einen schönen
guten Abend nach Mainz von Hannelore
Elsner die Rilke lesen glücklich machte
bis Lady Gaga die sich Rilke auf den Arm
tätowieren ließ wieso geht uns Rilke so
ans Herz
ich glaube Herz ist genau das richtige
Stichwort Rilke ist sicher einer der
ganz großen trostdichte ihm ist das
gelungen was Literatur in ihren
glücklichsten Momenten kann nämlich
Gefühle wie der Mensch eigentlich gar
nicht so gerne hat Wehmut sehen sucht
Einsamkeit alle Arten eben und
Schattierungen von Welt Schmerz und er
schafft das das so auszudrücken dass
darin auf einmal sowas ähnliches wie
Glück aufblitzt und das ist eine große
große Kunst und wie hat er das gemacht
welche Kniffe hat er da verwendet
naja ich kann ihn jetzt auch nicht den
Rilke quasi in 30 Sekunden runter
analysieren aber was natürlich jetzt so
interessant ist durch dieses unglaublich
große Archiv was uns dann zur Verfügung
stehen wird er ist ja durchaus mit so
einem
genialischen umgeben also wenn man eben
sagte das sind diese die sie ja fast
schon man kann sagen auch Fischen Sänger
also die von irgendwelchen mysteriösen
Kräften ihre Kunst eingeflüstert kriegen
von Göttern von Musen und dann ist das
große Kunstwerk da und der berichter vom
Literaturarchiv hat es ja schon gesagt
jetzt sehen wir plötzlich nein nein
dieser Rilke hat schon auch richtig
streng gearbeitet an seinen Texten das
ist nicht nur Eingebung sondern harte
lyrische Arbeit und das zu sehen ist
natürlich spannend
23.000 Seiten aus dem Nachlass kommen
jetzt an die Öffentlichkeit darunter
sind dann auch Gedicht Fassungen die
Rilke ja selbst verworfen hatte kann man
das überhaupt in seinem Interesse sein
dass wir die jetzt kennenlernen zunächst
mal muss man feststellen dass Rilke der
ja ein wahnsinnig rastloser Geist war
der hatte ja zig Adressen hat sich
meistens in angenehmen Gegenden von
reichen Menschen aushalten lassen ähm
dass der das aufgehoben hat also wenn er
wirklich gesagt hätte das interessiert
keinen mehr hätte er sie auch einfach
entsorgen können also die Tatsache dass
er das alles aufbewahrt hat spricht
dafür dass er es für wichtig gehalten
haben muss und ich habe gerade noch mal
nachgeschaut das Testament von Rilke
kann man lesen das ist in einem Band
veröffentlicht und er war ein Jahr vor
seinem Tod sehr sehr entspannt was sein
Nachlass angeht also zum Beispiel wir
werden morgen im literarischen Quartett
über ein Werk was jetzt aus Nachlässen
erschienen ist reden den Briefwechsel
zwischen Ingeborg Bachmann und Max
Frisch da ist die Lage ganz klar
Ingeborg Bachmann wollte kategorisch
nicht dass die Zeugnisse dieser
dramatischen und am Schluss sehr
quälenden verletzenden Liebe und
Trennung dass die öffentlich werden
Rilke schreibt in seinem Testament auch
Briefe könnt ihr sowieso alle
veröffentlichen unproblematisch und was
das Gedächtnis an mich angeht es kommt
eh nur drauf an was im Herzen von denen
geblieben ist die mich geliebt haben so
ungefähr mit dem Rest macht was ihr
wollt schon gesagt selbst im Testament
von ihm trotzdem so ein bisschen die
Frage wenn er dann quasi entzaubert wird
auch jetzt schon in seiner Arbeitsweise
haben wir gerade im Beitrag kurz gesehen
und so ein bisschen auf den Boden der
Tatsachen zurückgeholt wird ist das dann
etwas Gutes oder sollten wir ihn nicht
lieber als eine Art Genie in Erinnerung
behalten ich finde das ist kein Problem
wenn klar wird das auch genießt
gearbeitet haben man wieder
möglicherweise ein arbeitendes Genie
sein und man muss sich auch klar machen
das ist ein verlorengehen des Kulturgut
weil die allermeiste Literatur entsteht
ja doch seit einer Weile einfach digital
am Bildschirm das heißt solche kostbaren
Schätze wo man auch eine Handschrift
sieht wo man sieht wie manisch jemand
seiten zugeschrieben hat oder
dergleichen das ist möglicherweise in 50
60 Jahren Weg die einzige Gefahr die ich
sehe ist diese neigen ja seit einer
Weile dazu große moraldebatten auch an
um Kunst zu führen also Werk und Autor
eben gar nicht mehr zu trennen sondern
zu sagen wenn der Autor sich irgendwie
zu dubiosen Figur wird dann ist
möglicherweise dadurch auch das Werk
befleckt und man weiß ja nicht was da
alles zu Tage kommt also Rilke war
sicher er einer von den größeren Frauen
Verschleiß sondern eben er war ein
begnadeter er hat in seinen späten
Jahren in den 20ern sogar mit Mussolini
irgendwie geliebig da gibt es bereits
Briefe die man kennt also man weiß nicht
was da alles zu Tage kommt und das fand
ich nicht unproblematisch wenn also dann
über Blicke die so groß und moraldebatte
hereinbricht darf man jetzt noch Herr es
ist Zeit genießen als Gedicht oder eben
den berühmten Panther oder wird Rilke zu
einer schwierigen Figur für uns also
sehr interessant sie haben uns das tolle
eingeordnet Theodor und ein ganz
herzlichen Dank und wir sind natürlich
doppelt gespannt jetzt auf das
literarische Quartett morgen abend um
23:45 Uhr im ZDF vielen Dank nach Berlin
das ist schon weg
aber wir haben noch ein bisschen Rilke
zwei Mal nämlich jeweils Monate lang war
Rilke auf Reisen in Russland er war
Russland verfallen jedenfalls seiner
Idealvorstellung von dem Land in Lodge
in Polen setzen sich 56
außenministerinnen und Minister heute
mit einem anderen Russland auseinander
die Organisation für Sicherheit und
Zusammenarbeit in Europa der Russland
angehört tagt ohne den Chef Diplomaten
aus Russland und hat dabei ein Thema das
überall steht nämlich Russland die EU
sucht nach Wegen um die russische
Führung wegen Kriegsverbrechen zur
Verantwortung zu ziehen und räumt
gleichzeitig ein dass das Jahre dauern
könnte nach eigenen Angaben hat die
Ukraine bereits 40.000 russische
Kriegsverbrechen registriert Hannah
Hebestreit war in einem Dorf bei herson
auf Spurensuche
es ist eine Fahrt über schlammige Pisten
zu dem Dorf brach Dino westlich von
Restaurant vor wenigen Wochen ist hier
noch gekämpft worden ukrainische Truppen
haben einen hohen blutsoll gezahlt bis
sie die Russen in die Flucht schlagen
konnten in die Freude über das Ende der
Besatzungszeit mischt sich jetzt
Entsetzen immer neue Spuren russischer
Übergriffe werden
sichtbares russische Soldaten haben hier
sechs junge Männer aus der Region
erschossen die bei uns im Ort als
Erntehelfer gearbeitet haben einer war
früher angeblich beim Militär
war ein 16-jähriges Mädchen
so Vertuschung wohl sprengten die Russen
das Haus behaupteten es sei von
ukrainischen Granaten getroffen worden
Nachbarn beerdigten später die Leichen
der sechs Männer im Garten vor wenigen
Tagen hat Sergi ukrainischen Ermittlern
geholfen die sterblichen Überreste für
weitere Untersuchungen auszugraben dabei
fanden sie Spuren eines mutmaßlichen
Kriegsverbrechens
in einem der Schädel konnte man ein Loch
erkennen
das war ganz klar dass die Person
erschossen wurde
bei drei anderen Körpern haben wir
gesehen dass Seile um die Handknochen
gebunden waren
gehen die ukrainischen Ermittler über
500 Hinweisen auf Kriegsverbrechen nach
ihren kraftino haben russische Truppen
offenbar weitere Menschen gezielt
getötet
wir haben keine weiteren davon gefunden
es gab aber noch andere Vorfälle
bewaffnete Russen haben direkt hier im
Ort sie will ist in erschossen
noch ist unklar welche russischen
Einheiten wann in kraftino gewütet haben
Augenzeugen zeigen uns Gräber von Opfern
die man wohl Übergriffen
paramilitärischer Einheiten wie der
wagnergruppe kurz vor Abzug der Besatzer
zuordnen kann
unsere 28 Brigade Mitte Oktober mit der
Befreiung von brav Dino startete sind
Panzer dieser russischen Privatarmee in
nadias Garten Gefahren sie hat sie
angeschrien hat geschimpft da haben Sie
Nadja mit dem Maschinengewehr erschossen
den Leichnamen der 16-Jährigen Victoria
aus dem gesprengten Haus haben die
Ermittler auch mitgenommen sie suchen
nach weiteren Beweisen für
kriegsverbrechenden
und jetzt der Blick hier auf weitere
wichtige Nachrichten und den hast du
Hanna wegen der hohen Energiepreise hat
der Bundestag mit großer Mehrheit
weitere Hilfen auf den Weg gebracht
Studierende und Fachschüler bekommen
einmalig 200 €. die Auszahlung soll
digital beantragt werden und im
kommenden Jahr erfolgen wann genau ist
allerdings noch nicht klar außerdem
debattierte der Bundestag heute zum
ersten Mal über die geplante Gas und
strompreisbremse dabei wurden vielfach
Nachbesserungen gefordert die Opposition
kritisierte das Vorhaben unter anderem
als zu kompliziert und ungerecht die
gedeckelten Preise sollen von Januar
2023 bis Ende April 2024 gelten
bei seinem Besuch in Peking hat
EU-Ratspräsident Michelle den
chinesischen Staats-
Berliner Wende damit es auf Russland
einwirke die un-kater zu respektieren
bis heute hat Peking den Angriffskrieg
auf die Ukraine nicht verurteilt
US-Präsident beiden hat Frankreichs
Präsident macron zu einem Staatsbesuch
im Weißen Haus empfangen wegen der
russischen Aggression beschworen beide
einmal mehr eine langjährige tiefe
Freundschaft zwischen ihren Nationen
ganz oben auf der Agenda stand
allerdings auch ein Streit Thema die
milliardenschweren us-subventionen für
Produkte made in USA diese stoßen in
Frankreich und Teilen der EU auf massive
Kritik nach den Gesprächen sagten beide
dass sie in dieser Sache eng
zusammenarbeiten wollen
nachdem der als rechtsextrem eingestufte
ex-afd-abgeordnete Jens Meyer im
vergangenen Jahr den Wiedereinzug in den
Bundestag verpasst hatte wollte er
zurück in seinen alten Job als Richter
doch das Dienstgericht Leipzig hat ihn
nun in den vorzeitigen Ruhestand
versetzt das Vertrauen der
Öffentlichkeit in Meier habe so großen
Schaden genommen dass seine
Rechtsprechung nicht mehr glaubwürdig
erscheine hieß es zu Begründung Sachsens
Justizministerin sprach von einem
bundesweit richtungsweisenden Urteil
noch kann Maja dagegen Revision einlegen
nach der Explosion einer Briefbombe in
der ukrainischen Botschaft in Madrid am
Mittwoch sind in Spanien weitere
Postsendungen mit verborgenen
Sprengsätzen entdeckt worden so wurde
heute unter anderem in der US-Botschaft
eine verdächtige Sendung gefunden und
kontrolliert gesprengt und bereits
vergangene Woche war eine Briefbombe
unschädlich gemacht worden die an
Spaniens Ministerpräsident Sanchez
gerichtet war die spanischen
Sicherheitsbehörden schließen einen
Zusammenhang mit dem Krieg in der
Ukraine nicht aus
wir werden dafür sorgen und ich rufe die
Kliniken dazu auf das zu tun wir werden
Personal aus den regulären Erwachsenen
Stationen in die Kinderstationen
verlegen insbesondere Pflegepersonal das
ist eine Mischung aus Ansage und Appell
heute von Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach und er weiß dass er an
sichtbaren Ergebnissen gemessen werden
wird denn die Lage ist besorgniserregend
und es geht um die aller kleinsten ein
Oberarzt sagt Kinder sterben weil wir
sie nicht mehr versorgen können
Deutschland im dezember 2022 Sibylle
Basler
die onkologische Kinderstation der
Uniklinik Regensburg
bei der morgendlichen Übergabe mitten
rein ein Anruf vor dem sich derzeit die
meisten Kinderkliniken fürchten
ein Notfall doch die Station ist voll
nichts geht mehr was heißt das jetzt das
ist eigentlich gut
vertrösten müssen im schlimmsten Fall
bedeutet
Kinder müssen sterben weil es kein Platz
im Krankenhaus für sie gibt ein Albtraum
auch für die Menschen die hier arbeiten
und ich fühle mich damit schlecht nicht
ausreichend Betten zu haben nicht
ausreichend Pflegekräfte zu haben die
die Kinder versorgen den Krebs wartet
nicht
zehn Kinder und Jugendliche können hier
behandelt werden hanna ist seit Juli
hier gemeinsam mit ihrem Vater Christian
meine Tochter
zum zweiten Mal ihre geholfen muss weit
bis möglich ist und soweit wie es geht
er sei sehr dankbar so Hannas Vater dass
sie hier sein dürfen die Situation in
Regensburg kein Einzelfall auch in der
hornischen Kinderklinik in München sind
sie in großer Not
Personalmangel dazu die massive
rs-viruswelle die kleinen Patienten
trifft es mit voller Wucht für der Vater
eines kleinen Jungen da muss eine
Infusion zum Beispiel an dann sieht man
das in einer Notaufnahme momentan sehr
viel los ist und sehr lange Wartezeiten
sind bis zu zehn Stunden musst du immer
warten
lange Wartezeiten keine Betten
verzweifelte Eltern sind mittlerweile an
der Tagesordnung
die Situation ist hier das auch in der
Notaufnahme teilweise über Nacht
Patienten Mütter mit ihren Kindern Väter
mit ihren Kindern übernachten diese
Situation haben wir jetzt mehrfach
gehabt bundesweit klagen die Kliniken
über die katastrophalen Zustände jede
zweite muss Patienten wegschicken weil
sie kein freies Bett mehr hat so eine
aktuelle Umfrage und der intensiv und
notfallmedizinern die Lage ist höchster
dramatisch denn wir müssen den ganzen
Tag überlegen eben wenn da ein Bett ist
welcher Patient bekommt ist und welcher
eben auch nicht der Notruf aus den
Kinderkliniken langfristig plant Berlin
die Abschaffung der Fallpauschalen und
eine 300 Millionen Euro Spritze schnelle
Hilfe in der aktuellen Misere soll unter
anderem auch durch personalverschiebung
geleistet werden und ja appelliere ich
auch insbesondere an die Kliniken
planbare Eingriffe dann zu verschieben
so dass wir mehr Potenzial haben die
Kinder zu versorgen zurück nach
Regensburg die kleine Hanna darf bald
nach Hause und die nächsten kleinen
Patienten warten schon
im heute-journal Update nachher
dringende Fragen zur Situation von Nazan
gökdemir an Professor Johannes Hübner er
ist Kinderarzt an der Uniklinik München
aber erst noch mal Johanna
über das seit Jahren gestritten wird das
EU Freihandelsabkommen mit Kanada
nämlich doch nun hat der Bundestag das
ceta-abkommen ratifiziert Frank Bethmann
was für Vorteile soll ceta genau bringen
und was befürchten die Kritiker ja die
Befürchtungen waren das damit
klimapolitische Anstrengungen und
Verbraucherrechte unterlaufen oder auch
Rechtswege umgangen werden könnten
insbesondere die Grünen hatten sich
daher lange gewehrt nun hat es
einerseits Nachbesserungen gegeben aber
vor allem hat ein Umdenken stattgefunden
angesichts des russischen
Angriffskrieges und einer immer größer
werdenden Abhängigkeit von China gibt es
verstärkt Rückenwind für neue
freihandelsallianzen und so wurden 2021
nach Kanada bereits deutsche Güter im
Wert von 10 Milliarden Euro exportiert
die Importe summierten sich auf über 6
Milliarden das macht zwar nur 0,6% des
gesamten deutschen Handelsvolumens aus
Tendenz aber deutlich steigend wie der
giandura Präsident des
großhandelsverbandes BGA ergänzt wir
verdanken dem Abkommen dass die
Ausfuhren nach Kanada in den letzten
fünf Jahren um mehr als ein Viertel
gestiegen sind wissen muss man das trotz
der Ratifizierung erst heute 10 bereits
seit fünf Jahren weitgehend wie es heißt
vorläufig angewendet wird und daher
bereits Zölle auf 98% aller Waren
entfallen Deutschland ist im übrigen
nicht das letzte Land gewesen
Unterschriften unter dem ceta-vertrag
fehlen beispielsweise noch aus
Frankreich und Italien vielen Dank für
diese Einordnung gerne
ja galt als einer der prägendsten
Architekten der Gegenwart Meinhard von
gerkhan ist im Alter von 87 Jahren
gestorben der einflussreiche deutsche
Architekt war vor allem für seine
modernen Funktionsbauten aus Stahl und
Glas bekannt so baute ein von ihm
geleitetes Architektenbüro unter anderem
den Berliner Hauptbahnhof die beiden
hauptstadtflughäfen ber und Tegel sowie
weitere Bauwerke auf der ganzen Welt von
gerkhan wurde 1935 im lettischen Riga
geboren wie Gefährten würdigten ihn für
seinen offenen Blick in die Zukunft
und zwar Ergebnisse von der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft vom Nachmittag
Marokko steht erstmals seit 36 Jahren
wieder im Achtelfinale durch ein zwei zu
eins gegen Kanada sicherte sich Marokko
am Ende in der Gruppe F sogar den ersten
Platz die als Turnier mit Favorit
gehandelten Belgier schieben dagegen
durch die Nullnummer gegen Kroatien
bereits in der Vorrunde aus
ja und dann das Ergebnis des Abends
Deutschland Costa Rica 4:2 und dennoch
ist für die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft diese WM
vorbei das entscheidende Spiel ist
gerade zu Ende gegangen hier ist Peter
leisel mit den Höhe und Tiefpunkten
ein Feuerwerk muss her ein Feuerwerk an
Chancen und genauso beginnt die deutsche
Elf zweite Minute mussialer Schuss
Torwart Navas hat sich auf einen
intensiven Abend eingestellt vor allem
Jamal musiala Wirbel durch die
Abwehrreihen eifrig oft etwas übereifrig
mit Direktspiel und Flanken geht da mehr
Raum auf gnabry das eins zu 0 nach 10
Minuten durch einen von sieben Bayern
Spielern es war überfällig
es läuft zu Beginn wie geplant bei
Trainer flieg und dann schleicht sich
Fehler ein Rüdigers vor paar ermöglicht
die erste Chance der Mittelamerikaner
und was für eine
neuer rettet mit einer Hand das 1:0 zur
Pause war ich kein Ruhekissen und dann
die Hiobsbotschaft Japan für 2:1 gegen
Spanien Deutschland wäre trotz Sieg raus
für Krug soll es richten wie gegen die
Spanier und es kommt noch dicker die
deutsche Abwehr weit weg von Costa Ricas
angreifen
der Ausgleich für den Außenseiter
neuer kann den ersten Angriff noch
blocken dann kommt auch er zu spät
wütende Gegenangriffe der deutschen muss
Jala zunächst an den Pfosten artistische
Nachsitzen es wird ein Nervenspiel und
noch ein Pfostenschuss des 19-Jährigen
Münchners da wäre auch Navas zu spät
gekommen
die 70 Minute gibt es noch eine
Steigerung dieses verrückten Spiels es
gibt sie irgendwie kommt der Ball ins
deutsche Netz und Costa Rica führt und
wäre nach diesem stand tatsächlich
weiter die Favoriten Deutschland und
Spanien beide raus dass der Torschütze
Bosch ist heißt wird zur Nebensache mit
Götze und haarwärts bringt fliegt zwei
weitere frische Kräfte und habe es
gelingt wenig später nach Vorarbeit von
fünf Punkte Ausgleich zwei zu zwei seine
Einwechslung macht sich doppelt bezahlt
der Mann vom FC Chelsea ist nach Flanke
gnabry erneut zur Stelle
verhaltene Freude den Spanien spielt
nicht mit Deutschland wäre trotzdem raus
die Kräfte der Costa ricana lassen nach
Füllkrug völlig frei nicht im Abseits
4:2 ein Sieg der trotzdem große
Enttäuschung hervorruft die Niederlage
gegen Japan können Sie auch durch den
erwarteten Sieg nicht wett machen die WM
endet für sie wie 2018 nach der Vorrunde
[Applaus]
ja gewonnen gegen Costa Rica aber
dennoch draußen weil Japan gegen Spanien
gewann mit 2:1
ich habe nichts gedacht uns allen ging
das so es war ein Nichts totale Lehre
hat Manuel Neuer gesagt beim letzten
vorrundenhaus 2018 in Russland Sven Voss
in Katar guten Abend Sven wie sieht denn
die Mannschaft dass diesmal gewonnen
gegen Costa Rica dennoch raus was hat
gefehlt
ja Christian das ist alles noch schwer
in Worte zu fassen was hier gerade an
Dramatik passiert ist aber fest steht
das ist ein Albtraum aus dem der
deutsche Fußball so schnell nicht
erwachen wird zum zweiten Mal nach 2018
scheitert die deutsche Mannschaft in der
Vorrunde bei einer WM und das eine ist
das was hier im Albert Stadion hinter
mir zwischen Deutschland und Costa Rica
passiert ist und das was auf dem anderen
Platz im Parallelspiel zwischen Japan
und Spanien passiert ist die deutsche
Mannschaft hat gut gespielt fand schnell
rein ins Spiel hat das früher 1:0
gemacht hat dann aber verpasst
nachzulegen und dann wurde Costa Rica
plötzlich stark und die brauchen nicht
viele Chancen die sind sehr effektiv
waren zwischenzeitlich in Führung und
dann berappelt sich die deutsche
Mannschaft und gewinnt dieses Spiel noch
macht also ihre Hausaufgaben aber womit
man nicht rechnen konnte ist der
Überraschung Sieg von Japan im
Parallelspiel gegen Spanien deswegen ist
die deutsche Mannschaft hier und heute
ausgeschieden aber wenn man ehrlich ist
ausgeschieden ist sie eigentlich durch
diese bittere Niederlage im Auftaktspiel
gegen Japan das eins zu zwei denn auch
das war so nicht eingeplant und jetzt
darf man gespannt sein was im deutschen
Fußball passiert ich gehe davon aus dass
der jetzt kein Stein mehr auf dem
anderen bleiben wird ja Sven reden wir
noch kurz darüber was heißt denn das wir
gucken vielleicht noch ein Moment nach
vorne selbst an so einem Abend in
anderthalb Jahren ist em in Deutschland
wie geht's denn jetzt weiter
ja du sagst es das ist natürlich das
große Ziel auch für Hansi fliegt der in
der Pressekonferenz gestern noch mal
drauf angesprochen wurde was wäre denn
im Falle eines Ausscheidens könnte er
bestätigen dass er weitermachen dann hat
er gesagt ja wenn es nach mir geht
natürlich er freut sich auf die EM 20 24
aber ob das jetzt alles so in Stein
gemeißelt ist das weißt Du im Moment
keiner und dann gibt es Spieler wie
Manuel Neuer oder Thomas Müller die
hatten auch den Traum 20-24 die EM im
eigenen Land zu spielen in Deutschland
aber auch da ist jetzt die Frage ob das
die richtigen Spieler sind um jetzt den
so oft geforderten Neuaufbau hier an den
Start zu bringen also es wird
wahrscheinlich viel passieren nicht
direkt jetzt nicht in den Interviews
danach und vielleicht auch nicht morgen
wenn die Mannschaft dann um 14 Uhr
Ortszeit Richtung Deutschland fliegt und
dann in Frankfurt ankommen wird aber in
den nächsten Tagen Wochen Monaten muss
und wird sich was tun kein guter Tag für
den deutschen Fußball danke dir Sven
ja wir haben mit einem großen der
Dichtkunst begonnen wir enden auch mit
ihm natürlich passt Rilke auch jetzt
gibt Trost und Einordnung er hat gesagt
wer spricht von Siegen überstehen ist
alles
wobei ich jetzt nicht so ganz sicher bin
ob heute tatsächlich möglicherweise
nicht mal Rilke hilft wichtige und
hochspannende Diskussionsrunde nach uns
Heuchler oder Helfer kuscht der Westen
vor dem Iran ein Maybrit Illner Spezial
vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns waren
wünschen Ihnen einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend heute ist erster Dezember
meteorologischer Winteranfang laut
saisonprognose werden Dezember Januar
und Februar zusammen eher milder als
üblich Ausfall jetzt allerdings wird
erstmal kälter und das kommt so wenn am
Nordpol die Sonne untergeht kühlt die
Atmosphäre mehr und mehr aus diese
schwere Kaltluft hat Sogwirkung so
entsteht ein stark windband das nur in
den Wintermonaten existiert
normalerweise hält es die Eiseskälte
über den Pool gefangen dieser
Polarwirbel wird immer häufiger instabil
weil die Welt wärmer wird aktuell ist er
was alle paar Jahre passiert in zwei
Teile zerfallen so wird es in Sibirien
und Nordamerika eisig
und Hochs kommen da schon mal auf Abwege
wie dieses Hoch hier das in den nächsten
36 Stunden in Richtung Island und
Grönland sieht dann könnt ihr die
Strömung bei uns auf Nord drehen aktuell
kommt sie noch aus Südosten und da kommt
doch etwas Schnee mit heute Nacht also
kann es leicht Schnallen hier vor allen
Dingen in der Mitte Deutschlands im
Süden bildet sich etwas Nebel auf
Straßen und Gehwegen kann es glatt
werden denn die Temperaturen sinken auf
plus 4 bis -4 Grad und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen häufig nur wenig über
null Grad zum Teil bleibt auch
dauerfrostig vier oder fünf Grad gibt's
allenfalls in Wasser mehr und morgen tut
sich die Sonne weiterhin schwer es fällt
etwas Regen oder Schnee in den
Mittelgebirgen vielleicht ein oder zwei
Zentimeter Schnee und die ganz große
Wetterumstellung gibt's auch über den
zweiten Advent hinaus nicht guten Abend